ja die neuigkeiten sind in der tat nicht
angenehm sie sind dramatisch und sie
bestätigen den furchtbaren verdacht dass
alex navalny eben mit einem chemischen
kampfstoff vergiftet worden ist hierbei
handelt es sich um nur wie talk das ist
ein nervengift produziert vermutlich aus
einem russischen labor das ist 1991 zum
ersten mal auffallend geworden auffällig
geworden ist dann kontakt gift es wird
als chemische kampfmittel eingesetzt es
ist höchst toxikologisch und das labor
der bundeswehr hat bei einer
toxikologischen untersuchung eben diesen
kampfstoff jetzt nachweisen können und
navalny befindet sich immer noch in der
charité im krankenhaus er wird
untersucht er befindet sich immer noch
im koma
und was eben die ärzte schon damals
vermutet haben und für befürchtet haben
tritt wahrscheinlich ein durch dieses
novikov kann es eben nicht
ausgeschlossen werden dass alex
neuwahlen geben bleibende schäden
davonträgt
es führt auch zu multiplem organversagen
also das ist eine sehr sehr sehr
medizinisch höchst bedenkliche
angelegenheit mit der sich alexa wahlen
jetzt und die hat es auseinandersetzen
müssen und es bleibt abzuwarten ob er
überhaupt aus dem koma wieder erwacht
weil dieses gift ist extrem gefährlich